quelques heures après l’explosion dans
un village situé à la frontière entre
l'Ukraine et la Pologne
Varsovie a confirmé la mort de deux de
ses citoyens mais pour l'heure les
autorités polonaises restent prudentes à
l'inverse de celle de Kiev qui n'ont pas
attendu pour accuser la Russie
sur le territoire de l'OTAN est une
attaque russe contre la sécurité
collective c'est une escalade très
importante nous devons agir je vais dire
maintenant à tous nos frères et sœurs
polonais l'Ukraine vous soutiendra
toujours les gens libres ne seront pas
brisés par la terreur une accusation
très vite réfutée par Moscou les
déclarations des médias et des
responsables polonais concernant la
chute présumée de missile russe sont une
provocation délibérée visant à aggraver
la situation aucune frappe sur des
cibles proches de la frontière entre
l'Ukraine et la Pologne n'a été effectué
par des moyens de destruction russe de
leur côté l'OTAN et le Pentagone ont
annoncé à avoir pris connaissance des
informations fournies par les autorités
polonaises sans les confirmer pour le
moment le président du Conseil européen
lui s'est dit sous le choc
choqué par les nouvelles d'un missile ou
autre munitions ayant tué des personnes
sur le territoire polonais mais
condoléances aux familles nous sommes
aux côtés de la Pologne je suis en
contact avec les autorités polonaises
les membres du Conseil européen et
d'autres alliés
le président français Emmanuel Macron a
annoncé avoir pris contact avec les
autorités polonaises ils souhaitent
qu'une enquête soit menée pour rétablir
les faits et que le sujet soit abordé
lors du sommet du G20 qui se tient
actuellement à Bali